welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and if that Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles endings left you a
little shell shock then this is the
video for you mutant Mayhem is now out
and throughout this video we're gonna be
talking about the movie's plot it's
post-credits scene and also our thoughts
on where things could be going in the
future there's a big character that I
haven't seen anyone talking about so
yeah lots of stuff to dive into and
they've actually set up a lot of things
for sequels in the future I don't want
to waste any more of your time but
obviously heavy spoilers ahead and with
that out the way let's get into the
video my son Michelangelo you have heart
Donatello you have wisdom Raphael you
have bravery and Leonardo honor
enough talk I dream about fighting every
night you've got a rage problem man it's
not a problem
okay so mutant Mayhem follows the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles as they
make their way out the sewers and into
the human world told by Splinter that
humans are evil people that never hit
the Thumbs Up Button they've remained in
the shadows away from the light however
that will constantly cause of them and
whether it's seeing Ferris Bueller's Day
Off or just sell up for martial arts
movies they really want to be part of
that world now after saving April
O'Neill's scooter they see an
opportunity to finally be accepted by
humanity and this puts them on a path to
clash with the movie's big bad played by
Ice Cube they get tempted by superfly's
ways and I have to admit even I was like
yeah join them mate seems like seems
like a pretty seems like a Superfly dude
you could say however they realize it's
going to be a bad day if they stick with
them because Superfly actually wants to
Med all Humanity so mutants can rule a
planet
he's making a deal tonight under the
Brooklyn Bridge
huh I can't believe there are other
mutants you want to roll with us
humans are never gonna like us
so we're gonna let the mutants rule the
Earth
peoples they got to go okay um sort of a
Twist the film actually opens with
superfly's Father Baxter Stockman who's
voiced by none other than Giancarlo
Esposito you might be wondering why they
didn't just make backs to Stockman the
main villain as in the source material
he mutates into a fly there are theories
that stalkerman was originally going to
change into the villain and if we look
at the action figures we can see he has
human clothes Superfly also has the same
Harris Stockman and it seems like that
was the original plan Jeremy Johns
brought this up in his review and he
actually thinks that because the origin
story would be too similar to the movie
The Fly that there'd be some legal
trouble so they changed after green
lighting the figures either way I think
Ice Cube does a Stella job and we see as
he takes his other brothers to safety
when Stockman gets killed now this is
ordered by a woman named Cynthia who
plays a big part in the film's
post-credits scene once I get into who
she's actually gonna be I think you guys
is it gonna go wild because they're
clearly setting up something big with
this specific character now she's got a
thick German accent and when she was
talking oh I was kind of sat there like
she she sounds a bit like Krang because
I enjoy seeing both people and animals
software and you my friends are both
then I realized she had pink sunglasses
in a yellow coat and I was thinking
that's a bit similar to the body he uses
too upon getting home I looked up his
surname and as soon as I saw it was
utrom it all came together now in case
you don't know crang species is actually
related to the e-troms with krang's
design being inspired by the alien
species from the original TMNT comics
these are known as the trci aliens and
in the movie Cynthia's organization has
that name too that stands for techno
Cosmic Research Institute and building
off the back of that we of course have
the Technodrome now Cynthia has a
fascination with the use that created
the mutants and I think I'm the sequel
that this will be what transforms her
into Krang I think she land create a
synthetic body based off herself that
brings across her glasses and the code
too who knows Krang might already be
inside her body already and using it as
a host but yeah lots of things to talk
about and lots of different
now we will talk about her more in just
a bit but I think it's important to bear
in mind that she is probably going to be
crying either way the turtles end up
heading out to stop Superfly and after
showing his Pals that they'll accept
them the entire group tends against the
villain and his evil plants upon
destroying his machine though they
inadvertently push him in the use into
the river surrounding Manhattan and this
mutates him into a giant Kaiju attacking
the city the group have to work together
to bring him down and whilst all this is
going on April reports on the story she
manages to get herself uncanceled after
her initial attempt at being a reporter
ended up in her being sick everywhere
she's still sick but yeah she's still
reports on the story so I guess that's
cool now showing the city that the
turtles are the good guy New York comes
together to help these guys out and they
manage to take down Superfly accepted
into society we end the movie with the
turtles and rolling in high school which
takes us into our post-credits scene it
has some phone footage of the gang
settling into the school and we also see
some of the stuff that they're getting
up to to Donatello actually gets a
couple of different anime references in
with his hoodie being another JoJo's
Bizarre Adventure which this studio
confirmed the whole plan to take out the
giant Superfly is also based on how the
scouts take out titans in Attack on
Titan Goku's face was also used for the
anime club too and there's several of
these references dotted throughout the
film I think Raphael was dealing with
his rage at wrestling classes I'm sure
Michelangelo was showing you had better
improvisation skills to Mark Ruffalo at
The Classy enroll that earlier April and
Leon Ordo Nardo hey they're still
working on the superfly case and the
tcri lab they ran into earlier in the
movie April is now bringing the news to
the school which is something she wanted
to do for the entire film now Leonardo
asks April to the prom and though she
makes it clear they're just friends we
see Cynthia's monitoring the group and
we discover she's called in some help
this comes in the form of Shredder who
we then cut two looking out of a
Manhattan also important to bear in mind
that Cynthia has Superfly in his own
mutated state so we will probably end up
seeing him return for the sequel too as
for Shredder it's been said by the
creative team that he'll be the big bad
in the upcoming sequel however they'll
also explore more of the world in a two
season animated series for Paramount
plus title tales of the Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles this will be overseen by
Punk gray and it'll go into more of the
family's Adventures before setting up
things for the sequel now I can see that
being centered around the arrival of
Shredder and the creation of Krang
there's been a ton of different
iterations of Shredder over the years
with this potentially being more in line
with the Ultron version of the character
from the 2003 animated series that
actually revealed that he had an utram
inside his body so they could end up
bringing Cynthia and Shredder into this
one thing however they may just go with
a more classic depiction that had him as
a master martial artist that was the
leader of the Foot Clan known as
urukusaki his rival Hamada Yoshi were
martial artists that both loved the same
woman known as Tang Shen depending on
what version you pick up depend depends
on what happens after this they all kind
of follow the same path though with
Tang's death being caused specifically
by saki in the 1990 film both the ocean
Shan fled to New York which is when the
former took up a construction job he
returned home one day to find her dead
and it was at this point that he was
ambushed by saki he was doing this that
his pet rat Splinter was freed and he
clawed saki's face Splinter then found
the ooze and turtles and as they say the
rest was history now they don't go that
way with splinter in this film so they
aren't tying things closely in with the
character's past in the 1987 cartoon
that also had Yoshi hiding out in the
sewers which is when Shredder dumped
mutagen into it that turn him into
Splinter I think they're just gonna
disconnect from all this stuff
completely and instead just kind of keep
Cynthia as the thing that connects to
their Origins there's also Superfly 2
and I kind of hope that if he's brought
across to the Future films that he ends
up seeing the errors of his ways they
are clearly keeping him around for a
reason and Ice Cube did such a good job
that I'd love to see him back either way
there's lots of things to look forward
to with the upcoming stories and after
watching this movie I'm really excited
to see what's next I love the claymation
animated style of the movie and though
it's definitely inspired by spider-verse
I don't feel like they're ripping it off
I don't think the movie quite lived up
to the heights of that and honestly if
you're an adult I don't know if you're
gonna find this quite as enjoyable as
those movies are this is clearly aimed
at kids but yeah it's an animated film
so you can't really blame it for that
and honestly I think kids should have
animated movies for them too I think
adults are still gonna have a good time
but being almost 35 years old I was kind
of like Yep this is fine I think kids
will enjoy it a lot though and yeah if
I'm Sun like I hated it I don't wanna I
don't that's not the case at all and I
want to make sure that I'll let you know
that I did have fun with it and one
thing that really solves this movie I
think is of course it's voice cast and I
couldn't believe how stacked it is so
many big names in it and they all bring
their a game to it without providing
Nuance performances that really sell the
movie I was saying that unfortunately I
didn't feel like April really worked for
me but I'm not sure if that's because
I'm too attached to the older versions
of the character she's clearly been
brought in as an awkward teen rather
than what I always beat her as which was
a woman in her 20s covering the story
for the news network they're obviously
leaning in with the teenage part of the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles thing and
keeping them all around that age to what
she originally was your mileage may vary
on that but yeah this is clearly the
direction they want to go with that and
to be fair in the context of the movie
you know it does work I think just when
you have an attachment to older versions
of characters you know that becomes what
you think the character should be and
it's difficult for New Visions to break
that so yeah if you disagree let me know
below now though I haven't talked about
Jackie Chan's Splinter merch I think he
does an incredible job and he really
delivers the kind of disapproving dad
who just wants the best for his kids
role really well he also has a great
moment where he gets to shine at the
movie's midpoint and yeah it's one of my
favorite depictions of Splinter that
we've ever had glad they got such a big
martial arts actor to do it as well and
it had some extra authenticity to what's
already a stacked movie I think the
meetings are brilliant too and they
really added the film with their little
quips and jokes I've always been used to
Bebop and Rocksteady being bad guys but
I think they work really well swapping
sides and joining up with the turtles
they might change them out in the future
though and potentially the pair could
end up siding with shredder in a feature
film so they're more in line with their
original takes I also really like the
central story around the teens too and
watching them longingly want to have a
normal life adds so much to the movie
just seeing them hanging out you know it
builds on their characters and I like
that we got lots of scenes where they
were just chatting rubbish and doing
dumb stuff really makes this movie more
than what could have been just another
turtle's film and with there being so
many depictions they do need to add
their own style and Flair to it which I
definitely think they bring so yeah I
think they've accomplished everything
they set out to do and they gave us an
enjoyable movie that's got some really
good animation and characters within it
they've also got some great Easter eggs
in it too and hearing vanilla ices go
ninja go ninja go on the radio at one
point you know it made me crack a smile
there's also lots of interesting ways
that they can take a sequel and I think
in the end we've got a solid star to the
franchise Paramount are clearly
confident too to be investing so much
into its future and I am excited to see
where things go from here so yeah let me
know your thoughts on the film below and
also what you want to see in the future
of the franchise please drop a like on
the video and if you want to support the
channel as a member of the spoiler
Society then please click the join
button you'll get early access to videos
every week and it goes such a long way
to helping us out you want to get some
heavy spoilers merch we've also just
launched our t-shirt line locate below
the video that will let you pick up all
kinds of tops like a few time one house
of the Dragon stuff Marvel teas and a
lot more we drop new designs on there
all the time too so definitely keep an
eye out and yeah thanks again for
supporting us now if you want something
else to watch we've got a video on
screen right now breaking down the
recent Loki trailer that just got
released obviously over there right
after this but if not you enjoy the rest
of your week and yeah check out next
time by the way I've been Paul you've
been the best I'll see you next time
take care peace
foreign